jetzt liebe zuschauer ist es offiziell
jetzt ist amtlich martin schulz ist
kanzlerkandidat der spd zum vorsitzenden
gewählt letztes wochenende mit sagen wir
mal ganz ordentlich 100% 100 und was war
das was war das für eine schöne
krönungsmesse da in berlin
emotionen pur genossen haben sich vor
begeisterung die klamotten vom leib
gerissen stundenlange ovationen blinde
konnten wieder gehen da war alles dabei
alle und hier kommt der geilste moment
gültige stimmen 600 und 5 mit ja haben
gestimmt 600 und 5 benötigen
ach du scheiße jetzt bin ich wirklich
der chef von im auge warum bin ich nicht
buchhändler geblieben im hörsaal ja herr
schulz steht für den charme des neuen
was ganz amüsant es beim dienstältesten
spd-präsidiumsmitglied seit 1999 trägt
der mann wirklich jeden scheiß mit den
die partei verkommen
hauptsache emotionen hier super
kitschiger spd sport zur krönung ganz
wichtig nicht von uns bearbeitet
drei buchstaben rbb
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alte regel in zeitlupe kriegst du jeden
sexy meine damen und herren ich gucke
mir die bälle gleich konnte noch mal
ziehen wer schuld kann sie alle haben
also ich möchte seine 100 prozent an
dieser stelle wirklich nicht kleinreden
aber natürlich war der gabriel überdruss
in der partei so gigantisch dass sie
selbst diesen ficus mit 100 prozent
gewählt
wirklich ist schon erstaunlich denn
eigentlich fordert schulz original
nichts was die vorsitzende vor ihm nicht
auch gefordert hätten
aber stellen sie fest er autorisiert
haltig fans endlich einer der die ärmel
hochkrempeln dass man sagen kann der
haut mit dem erfolg haben
butter bei die fische hier geht's jetzt
zur sache mit ihm alles nur so larifari
wow ich fast alles dabei was wir
deutschen straßen lexikon hergibt dafür
da eigentlich nur noch flussmitte
patenten mein lieber herr kokocinski und
natürlich hinten hat der fuchs die eier
und war alles dabei
[Applaus]